[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Hello, there and welcome
to episode number 173 of the
weekly "Google Cloud Platform
Podcast."
I'm Mark, and I'm
here with Michelle.
Hello, Michelle.
MICHELLE CASBON: Hi, Mark.
How's it going?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I'm going well.
How are you?
MICHELLE CASBON: At
least you're going.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I'm going well.
I'm not staying well,
but I'm going well.
MICHELLE CASBON: I'm doing well.
I'm really excited
about our topic today.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: OK,
what is our topic today?
MICHELLE CASBON: We're
talking Cloud Run.
We had an action-packed
week last week.
We were very busy at Cloud Next.
The show kept us running
on our feet all week long,
but we have something
really exciting to share
with you today.
It's news that we'd been
sitting on for months,
and we're very excited to
be able to talk about it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, I think there's
a lot of buzz about Cloud Run.
And I think that it was kind of
one of the major announcements
out there.
It's something that people have
been asking for because Google
has all these different
serverless offerings,
but there was none
that kind of just
fit that real nice point
that Cloud Run comes into,
which is, like, I've
got a container.
I want to make it in the
Cloud-- go host things.
Bam, Cloud Run just does that.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Yeah, that's right.
So this is a gap
that people have been
asking about for a long time.
And we finally have all
the details for you.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
we're going to talk
about that in just a second.
But before that, we've got
to talk about the cool thing
of the week.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Only one thing, Mark?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, if
we had to make it one thing,
why not make it a
list of 122 things?
MICHELLE CASBON:
I like your style.
There was an announcement that
listed all of the cool things,
but we'll just cover
a couple of them.
If you want to go
into detail, you can,
but we'll just talk
about our favorites.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah,
I think that if you
want to click through
the link, which
will be in the description,
it talks about basically
all the cool things that got
announced-- a lot of product
announcements, a lot of
additions to existing products,
a lot of expanded feature sets.
You know, I'd like to talk about
network service tiers, which
is really cool for
people who kind of want
to put a little bit
more customization
into their projects
because typically speaking,
you know, Google has this
ultra-high fast network.
And that's great and, you
know, it's super, super good.
But at the same
time, a lot of people
don't actually take usage
of that speed, right?
And when every
millisecond counts,
you want to make sure that
you use that premium tier.
But what happens if
you're not as concerned
if something gets there in a
couple of seconds or whatever,
right?
That's where you can use
the new standard tier
to just kind of jump in.
And the key part here
is the standard tier
is cheaper, right?
So now, you actually
have flexibility
to say, OK, well, let's put the
projects that aren't mission
critical or the
ones that are just
development projects-- let's
put those on standard tier
so we can actually save
a little bit of money,
and then kind of just have that
better optimization to be like,
do I want to pay for
better performance
or go with the
standard performance?
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah, nice.
So that's the backbone
for a lot of the services
that we run, so it's good
to have different options
for people to choose from.
One of my favorite
announcements was Cloud Code.
We demoed this.
We got to see this up
on the keynote stage
during the developer keynote.
This is something
that I got to try out
about a month or so ago.
And I absolutely loved it
because it's essentially
an IDE for developing
code on Kubernetes.
It cuts out a lot
of the manual steps
and automates a lot of
those tasks for you.
So I really love Cloud Code.
I love what that
team has done for us.
We had a couple of other
exciting announcements.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Many cool things.
MICHELLE CASBON:
I'm also really happy to hear
that Cloud SQL now supports
PostgreSQL 11 just last week.
So I gave a session
at Next last week.
And in my demo, I showed
off PostgreSQL v9.
I had no idea that v11
would be available,
so that's especially exciting.
A couple of other things
that I really liked--
Cloud Data Fusion.
It's a GUI for
running ETL pipelines.
So completely code
free, it's a way
of integrating with a lot of
different types of data stores.
And you don't need a
whole lot of expertise.
This reminds me of my
days as a data engineer.
If you haven't tried
that, check it out
if you do any type of
ETL or data engineering.
There were also a lot
of exciting developments
in the Cloud AI platform space.
There were quite a few sessions.
There was one on using
deep learning images.
When you check out my session,
it was on using Kubeflow.
Quite a few things part
of the AI platform.
One of them that I really liked
was AutoML Natural Language,
which brings me back to my days
as a startup where we tried
to build something similar.
Now, we have a solution.
That one lets you
do-- without having
to know a whole lot about data
science or machine learning,
it's an API that you can
call and get predictions
about your text data.
A few other exciting things--
OK, just two more.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: All
right, two more, two more.
MICHELLE CASBON: These
are G Suite add-ins.
I thought these were
especially interesting.
So Google Voice for G Suite--
that means your business
accounts-- you can have a phone
number from anywhere that you
can access your G Suite
account, and also Hangouts chat
from Gmail.
So if you are a
G Suite user, you
have those two nice
things waiting for you.
OK, one more cool thing.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: OK, OK.
Well, you said two more.
All right, go for one more.
MICHELLE CASBON: OK, so this
is one of the Cloud AI platform
announcements.
This is actually an
open-source announcement.
Kubeflow released its
0.5.0 release last week.
So that's out on GitHub.
You can find it if you were
a previous Kubeflow user.
This one has a ton
of changes, and I
promise that you'll like
them-- really nice UI changes,
a lot of pipelines features,
and a ton of enterprise support.
So that's something
that I've personally
been working on very hard
in the lead-up to Next,
so I'm especially excited
to see that out in the open.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
one extra cool thing
among a lot of
smaller cool things,
definitely check
out that blog post.
I think you'll see a
kind of a cool highlight
list of all the different
product announcements-- again,
those feature releases.
A lot of cool stuff there.
Definitely worth checking out.
But since we're here to
talk about Cloud Run,
why don't we just go ahead and
dive right into the interview?
MICHELLE CASBON: Sounds great.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GABRIELA FERRARA: I'm
here with Steren and Ryan.
They're going to be talking
about Google Cloud Run.
STEREN GIANNINI: Hi, I'm Steren.
I'm a product manager
on the serverless team
at Google Cloud.
RYAN GREGG: And I'm Ryan Gregg.
I'm also a product manager
on the serverless team
at Google Cloud.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Cool.
Tell us more about
the announcement
from today from the Cloud Run.
STEREN GIANNINI: So 10 minutes
ago, we announced Cloud Run--
something we've been working
on for a very long time now.
And we are so excited to
release it to the world
and introduce it to everybody.
So Cloud Run basically brings
serverless to containers.
It allows you to run
any HTTP stateless
workload on the
fully-serverless environment.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
first things first,
can you talk about, like, what
does serverless mean to you?
STEREN GIANNINI: We define
serverless with the following
characteristics.
First and foremost, it's
an operational model.
So you always use a
fully-managed infrastructure.
You always pay for what you use.
And you also have
a managed security.
And when you think about
it, with that definition
of serverless, you can realize
that it doesn't apply only
to function as a service.
It applies to even
more than just compute.
If you take that definition
and look at something
like Filestore, which is
a serverless database,
it meets those requirements.
And we qualify Cloud Filestore
as a serverless product
for data.
If we look at
serverless compute,
we can refine a bit
more, the definition.
We can add some
development model on top.
So when you develop for a
serverless compute environment,
you use what we call services.
So it's more serverfull
than serverless actually.
So you develop in term of
services-- maybe microservices.
All of them are
independently scalable
and they are stateless.
So really, they autoscale
based on their needs.
And more importantly, you only
pay for when you use them.
And that applies
to everything we
qualify as serverless,
including compute.
When you don't send
any traffic or events
to the function or
Cloud Run service,
then you just
don't pay anything.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, I mean, Google
has a history of
serverless products
that are out there, right?
GABRIELA FERRARA: BigQuery, for
instance, you pay what you use,
actually.
RYAN GREGG: Yeah,
you can actually
go back almost 11 years
now to App Engine.
You know, it wasn't
serverless at the time.
That word hadn't
been coined yet.
But you know, it really
focused on the idea of just
allow the developer
to focus on the code--
the thing that actually brings
value to their business--
and have Google take
care of everything else.
GABRIELA FERRARA: So interesting
you bring up App Engine
because one of the people
that I know always said like,
it's amazing product
that came out.
And people at the
time did not give it
much value that was due.
And I think now with
Cloud Run, and the thing
is going to be big, you
know, because now, you
can run anything on it--
any language, right?
RYAN GREGG: Yeah, that's right.
Because we're based on
using a Docker container
as the artifact
that you provide,
you can run any
language, any binary.
Any code that you can
put into a container
will run great on Cloud Run.
GABRIELA FERRARA: You could
create your own language
and put it in a container.
RYAN GREGG: You certainly could.
STEREN GIANNINI: You can.
Some of our alpha testers
have put into their containers
even a custom binary.
They don't even give us the
source code or anything.
They compile it somewhere
or maybe even themselves,
they got this binary
from somebody else.
And they run it in a free
serverless environment.
So indeed, we've heard from
App Engine customers or Cloud
Function developers
that they were
feeling a bit limited by
the available languages.
So you know, even if we support
a large variety of languages,
you always have this small
library that you wish
was available in App Engine.
You always has this
language that you
wish, oh, I wish Cloud Functions
supported that language.
With containers,
you can do anything.
You can put any
language in a container
or any software, any
binary, any library.
RYAN GREGG: In fact, one of
the demos that we're doing here
at Next is using OpenOffice in
a container to convert a Word
document into a PDF.
So we've taken, you know, old
legacy technology, embedded it
into the container, and then
we can run that serverlessly.
It's pretty cool.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
it sounds like there's
two different versions
of Cloud Run that
are kind of announced though.
What's the difference
between them?
RYAN GREGG: That's right.
So there's Cloud Run, which
is the fully-managed, hosted
service for running
serverless containers.
And there's Cloud
Run on GKE, which
provides many of
the same benefits,
but actually runs the compute
inside your Kubernetes
container.
So you get the same
autoscaling benefits.
You get the same
URL programming.
You get the same container model
and the same container runtime
contract, but the compute
itself is actually
running inside your
Kubernetes Engine cluster
with the same
APIs, the same CLI,
the same Cloud Console
interface being
able to deploy
across both of them.
So you get a great
story for being
able to use the platform
that makes the most
sense for your
organization, whether that's
a fully-managed hosted compute
product or the Kubernetes
product that you may
have already invested in.
GABRIELA FERRARA: For instance,
I already have, let's say,
a GKE cluster that
I run some software.
What kind of scenario
Cloud Run would
be useful for that to
run in there and not
in a managed service.
RYAN GREGG: There's a
number of different reasons
why you might choose to do this.
For one, you have a
lot more customization
in the types of compute
platform that you're running on.
So if you need a bigger CPU
or more modern CPUs that
are available on Kubernetes,
you can have those.
You can use high-memory
nodes in Kubernetes,
so you can have access to a
lot more RAM than what you'll
have on the hosted service.
It also lets you run a
bunch of different workloads
together on the same
compute cluster.
So if you have workloads
that you've previously
deployed on Kubernetes
that you want
to have low latency next to,
you can deploy those workloads
into your Kubernetes cluster.
Kubernetes also gives you access
to hardware accelerators--
GPUs and TPUs.
So if you have
serverless workloads that
want to take advantage of
that hardware acceleration,
you can deploy those from Cloud
Run into Kubernetes Engine
and access the GPUs as well.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Machine
learning all the things, right?
RYAN GREGG: That's right.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So I mean, it's
fair to say that
if you were just
kind of getting started
with it, you'd probably want
to use the full serverless one.
RYAN GREGG: Absolutely, yeah.
If you don't have
Kubernetes already
or you just want to kick
the tires of Cloud Run,
the hosted service is
absolutely the way to go.
If you're a big organization
that has a big Kubernetes
investment, then using Cloud
Run on GKE probably makes sense.
STEREN GIANNINI:
And the good thing
is that it's super easy
to change your mind.
We have customers who told
us, oh, I deployed first
on the fully-managed
version of Cloud Run
because I was looking for
an easy way to get started,
but then I realized
I was needing
to be close to my GKE workload,
so I moved it to my cluster.
But from a developer
perspective,
they get the exact
same experience--
the exact same user interface,
the exact same command
line, the exact same API even.
RYAN GREGG: This whole strategy
that we have with Cloud Run
is really based on what we've
heard from customers who
have been using App Engine,
Cloud Functions, and Kubernetes
Engine, where sometimes
for an IT [? dev ?] need
or for some particular
reason, they
want to move what they have
done from App Engine into GKE.
And in the past, that was
actually somewhat difficult.
You had to think about how
to rebuild the application.
You had to learn how
Kubernetes worked.
There was a lot
that went into it.
Both Cloud Run and
Cloud Run on GKE, it's
actually just really simple.
You can just redeploy
the application container
into your Kubernetes Engine
and everything works.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Just take
it and chuck it over the wall.
[DISHES BREAKING]
You're good to go.
RYAN GREGG: Yep.
But you know,
workload portability
isn't the only
thing that we wanted
to focus on with portability.
We wanted to make sure that
the skills that developers were
building up while they
were using Cloud Run
were portable as well,
so that it wasn't just
that you were locked into
a serverless platform
with the knowledge
that you were gaining,
but you could deploy
it into Kubernetes
or through the open-source
Knative project
actually into any Kubernetes
cluster running anywhere,
including an
on-premises environment.
STEREN GIANNINI: I think we
have to give a little bit
more details here.
Cloud Run and Cloud
Run on GKE both
implement the
Knative Serving API,
which is an open-source
project we launched
last year at Cloud Next 2018.
And Knative itself, you can
install it anywhere Kubernetes
run.
So if you think
about it, that means
that the tooling that
you've built around this API
is not only compatible with
Cloud Run, Cloud Run on GKE,
but also with any
Knative implementation.
And we have many partners who
are authoring managed Knative
in their cloud platforms.
RYAN GREGG: Yep.
GABRIELA FERRARA:
That's how you keep
the scale to zero on your
cluster with Knative helping.
RYAN GREGG: Yeah, that's right.
One of the features that
Knative Serving offers
is the ability to scale to zero
inside the Kubernetes cluster.
So we don't change the way the
Kubernetes cluster is set up.
We don't change the provisioned
nodes in the cluster.
But we can scale the instances
of a container down to zero
or if you're familiar
with Kubernetes,
the pods in that cluster
down to zero for workload.
And there's another
really cool feature
that I think came out this
week, which is called GKE usage
metering, which lets
you, as an organization,
see how people are
using the resources
inside your Kubernetes cluster.
And so by combining Cloud Run
on GKE or Knative with that,
you can actually do
a scale-to-zero cost
for your internal teams when
how you charge them back
for the resources they're
using in your cluster.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
you've got this ability
now to take these containers
fully-portable move them
around, whether it's
Kubernetes hosted with Google,
Kubernetes hosted somewhere
else, you can kind of
move all these things around.
What's the best way
that someone's actually
going to start, like,
managing their build pipelines
with this?
STEREN GIANNINI: So of
course, everybody who
thinks container thinks Docker.
And Docker is an amazing
tool to build and push
your Docker container.
There is a very large
ecosystem around Dockerfile.
If you don't know
what a Dockerfile is,
it's the very
small file that you
put to describe how to build
your code into a container.
And don't be afraid if
you don't know them.
Take a look at them.
They are just a very
few lines of code
where you start
from a base image.
There are many official base
image-- like each language
community has official base
images posted on Docker Hub.
And you know, you
basically declare
what you want to install
into your container.
So Dockerfiles
and Docker overall
is an industry standard
today, but Google Cloud
provides ways to build your
containers in the cloud itself,
instead of your local
machines or on-premise.
So this product is
called Cloud Build.
So Cloud Build will take your
source and your Dockerfiles
and package this up
into a container image,
fully on demand.
So I consider Cloud
Build serverless.
You don't have to
see any servers.
You pay only when you build.
That qualifies as
serverless to me.
And so Cloud Build and Cloud
Run are a good match, right?
You go from your code
to build artifacts
that you build with
Cloud Build, and then you
deploy it to Cloud Run.
What's also super interesting
is that Cloud Build
has Cloud Build triggers.
What that means is
that I can decide
to trigger a build when I'm
pushing some commits into a Git
branch.
So now, we start doing
continuous integration
and continuous delivery because
every time the repo is updated,
Cloud Build will build a
container, and can also as you
want, but can also
deploy it to Cloud Run.
RYAN GREGG: I also add Cloud
Build is a phenomenal tool
for doing builds and doing
a lightweight CI, like what
Steren just described.
But the great thing about
using Docker containers
as the primitive for
deploying compute here
is that you can actually
use any CI/CD system
that you have already.
One of our launch
partners, GitLab,
is actually showing off some
of their serverless technology
here as well, where you can use
GitLab to deploy serverlessly
into Cloud Run or to Knative.
So you can use Cloud Build if
you're starting from scratch
or you can use your
existing CI/CD pipelines
to flow the container
straight into Cloud Run.
STEREN GIANNINI:
Last week, buildpacks
released a beta version
of the pack command line.
And buildpacks allow you
to go from source code
in various languages
directly to containers
without having to think
about Dockerfiles even.
I really recommend to
check out buildpacks.
It's a great match
to build containers
when you are a language expert.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Yeah, I
have trouble with Dockerfiles.
I always have to fight them
or I'd lose it and in the end,
someone helps me.
RYAN GREGG: Yeah, the great
thing about the pack command
line tool that just got
launched is that you can just
type one command inside
a folder with source,
and it leverages the buildpacks
to go ahead and create a Docker
container for you.
STEREN GIANNINI: Oh, so if
you are a Java developer,
I heard that JIB--
Java Image Builder--
was an amazing tool.
You just import a Maven
package in your pom.xml,
and then in one command,
you can build your Java app
into a container.
You don't even need
Docker installed locally.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, the Jib thing--
it was a couple weeks ago.
I think it was pretty recent.
It just came out.
And you can easily--
I think you said, Maven
or Gradle, put it in your
build pipeline, and then,
bam, in the same way,
you're building your
containers without having
to worry about all
the little tweaks
that you might need to
put in the Dockerfile.
RYAN GREGG: This is one
of the reasons we're
really excited about
having containers
as the primitive is because, you
know, there is so much tooling
and such a large ecosystem built
up around Docker containers
that you can use whatever
tools you want to be
able to deploy onto Cloud Run.
GABRIELA FERRARA: I never could
get past the Docker Compose.
Everybody said that
was easier to use,
but, like, I sticked with
the Dockerfile itself.
I'm going to check back.
STEREN GIANNINI: I would
recommend in the Cloud Run
Quickstart, we are giving
very simple Dockerfiles
in popular languages for
people to get started.
So if you're a Node.js
developer, don't be scared.
The Dockerfile is
literally five lines
from Node.js, npm
install, and npm start.
That's what it says.
GABRIELA FERRARA: The Cloud
Run was in alpha, right?
And now, it's in beta, correct?
STEREN GIANNINI: Correct.
RYAN GREGG: That's right.
GABRIELA FERRARA:
So what are people
are building on it usually?
STEREN GIANNINI: So we've
seen two major categories
of use cases.
The first one would be
exposing public services
to the internet.
So a lot of them have been
using Cloud Run to just build
websites, or APIs,
or mobile back-ends.
Some did chatbots,
where you expose
just a simple endpoint
that will reply
every time the request comes in.
This is all about
public microservices.
So the great thing
about Cloud Run
is that it will
automatically scale
based on incoming requests.
So if your website or API
is popular, no problem.
Cloud Run scales.
And if it's not,
well, no problem
either because Cloud
Run scales down to zero.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Hopefully, it's popular.
STEREN GIANNINI:
Hopefully-- we hope.
But we've also seen a
large amount of use cases
around private microservices.
So this would be
people who are using
Cloud Run to do data
transformation or image
analysis because the
interesting thing is that Cloud
Run integrates with Pub/Sub.
So from Pub/Sub, you can push
an event to a Cloud Run service
entirely privately without
having to expose anything
to the internet.
And Cloud Run has a request
timeout of 15 minutes.
That means that for 15 minutes,
you can process an image,
convert a DOC to a PDF
like we are doing today
during the demo.
So for example, we have
Airbus that you probably all
know-- they are using Cloud
Run to run inside a container
one of their custom binaries to
do image detection on satellite
images, completely
in a serverless way.
When they don't use it,
they don't pay anything.
It scales to zero.
And when they have a lot
of images to process,
well, it scales.
GABRIELA FERRARA: So 50 minutes
is the timeout you said?
STEREN GIANNINI: 15--
1-5.
GABRIELA FERRARA: 15, OK.
STEREN GIANNINI:
Yeah, on Cloud Run.
Cloud Run on GKE can do more.
RYAN GREGG: Yeah, we have a
little bit more flexibility
on the Kubernetes side to
make the timeout be longer.
But of course, it's still
based on the length of an HTTP
request, so you know, there's
some network stability issues
that you may encounter if
you try to push it too much.
GABRIELA FERRARA: I'm asking
because on Functions, it's
5 minutes if I recall--
6 minutes if I recall.
STEREN GIANNINI: I
think you can push it
to 9 on Cloud Functions.
GABRIELA FERRARA:
Last time used it,
and I was trying
to do an ETL on it.
And that was not a good idea.
RYAN GREGG: Cloud Run
will be a much better tool
for doing things like ETL for
real data processing work.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Oh, I
need to check that out.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, speaking of which
though, so now,
we've got Cloud Run.
We've got Cloud Functions.
And of course, we were just
talking about App Engine
earlier.
There's a lot of
different solutions here
that cover a lot of space.
We know that, you know, you
just kind of want a container.
You want to throw it up there.
Cloud Run sounds like
the best way to do it.
But if someone's getting
started with all of this
and someone says, oh, you
should go serverless, great.
But now, I've got at least three
different compute serverless
options to choose from.
What's kind of the best way
to guide them down that path?
Is there a decision tree?
Is there, like, a
couple of quick fixes?
What would make sense there?
STEREN GIANNINI:
So to start with, I
would say you have
to ask yourself
which level of abstraction
do I want to be at?
If you really want to attach
some very small snippet of code
next to your database, Cloud
Functions will be ideal.
You will just provide a
function to do one thing,
and it will scale on demand.
It builds for you.
You don't have to
deal with containers.
Functions have a
lot of event sources
that are not available in
Cloud Run or App Engine.
So you can also use
Function to do HTTP,
but more importantly,
event-triggered functions.
App Engine, I think, is
ideal for web workloads.
App Engine has been
designed for the web API,
or the website use
case, or maybe the web
back-end use case.
So App Engine is
source based, so it
will support now five or
seven languages very well.
And you know, you go from
your local source code,
you hit one command, and
boom, the thing is deployed.
You don't see the
containers on App Engine.
On Cloud Run, I would
say it's anything
that fits the container
contract of Cloud Run.
So here, your
imagination is the limit.
The contract is
that we are going
to send you events or
requests on an endpoint
to your container, and
then you handle the rest.
So Cloud Run would be for
anything else, I would say.
But the good news is
that the three of them
are built on the
same Google Cloud
serverless infrastructure.
They all share the same
sandbox technology,
allowing [INAUDIBLE] Google
to run unmodified languages
in the stack.
And maybe one last thing
is that Cloud Functions
is generally available, App
Engine is generally available.
Cloud Run literally launched
45 minutes ago to beta.
So depending on your
taste for risk--
RYAN GREGG: If you're trying
to go to production today,
I think App Engine or Cloud
Functions is definitely
the right choice for now.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: But
it's a great option
for people who want to get
started, maybe check it out.
STEREN GIANNINI:
And they all-- you
know, App Engine,
Cloud Functions
are fully-supported products.
We invested a lot into App
Engine in the past years
and keep investing.
We launched many new languages
on second-generation runtimes
on App Engine
standard environment,
and we keep improving.
At Cloud Next 2019, we
are announcing the ability
to connect to VPC networks
from App Engine, which
was a huge demand
from our customers.
So we are heavily investing
in those three products.
GABRIELA FERRARA:
That's very interesting
because on App
Engine, you couldn't
connect to the private network.
So if you wanted
to have something
that's a private process--
like, let's say, a
Kubernetes cluster
that you didn't put it outside--
and you have something
processing there called run,
you can use it now.
RYAN GREGG: Yeah, it used to be
that everything had to go over
the public internet to be
able to talk between App
Engine and something else.
But now with VPC
connect, you can actually
use the VPC to do all of
that internal network.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Anything else really
cool that you've seen at
Next that you're super
excited about?
STEREN GIANNINI: We are super
excited about introducing
Cloud Run to the world.
We've been holding the
announcement for so long now.
We've been interacting with
thousands of alpha testers
who gave us tremendous feedback.
If they are listening, I really
want to thank them for that.
They helped us
shape the product.
They helped us fix issues.
And now, we are really very
excited to give it to the world
and see what developers
will build with Cloud Run
because, you know, arbitrary
stateless containers
on a fully-serverless
environment--
I think the imagination
is the limit now.
You're not restricted
about anything,
so let's see what people
will build with it.
RYAN GREGG: Yeah.
And you thanked the thousands
of alpha testers that we had,
which we really could not have
made this product without.
I also want to thank the
open-source community
behind Knative.
You know, we have over 50
different organizations
who have been contributing
their time and energy
to make Knative awesome.
And Knative is
really the basis that
makes the portability story
of Cloud Run possible.
And so we're really
excited about all
of their contributions as well.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
It's really good
to see, like, what all these
teams kind of come together
with.
And like you said, this is a
big solution for developers
who come in here and say,
like, I want App Engine,
but I want it with containers
or I want functions,
but I need a little bit
more oomph behind it.
And that's kind of where
this problem comes in.
It's where it gets solved.
And it's really awesome
to see, like, look,
this is feedback that
you all have given us,
and this is what
we've done with it.
RYAN GREGG: Yeah, I'm
super proud of Cloud Run.
Like Steren said,
you know, we've
been working on this
for a little while.
And we're really happy
to have it launch today.
And we're really excited
to see what everybody
is going to use it for.
STEREN GIANNINI:
Yeah, give it a try--
cloud.google.com/run.
It's easy.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: You couldn't
get a better URL either.
STEREN GIANNINI: Exactly.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
And Gabi, you were
saying that you were
super excited because you
knew someone who was working
on a perfect use case for it.
GABRIELA FERRARA:
Yeah, I had someone
working on a just-in-time
compiler in a popular language
that doesn't have that.
I was like, imagine putting
that in a container.
And like, I'm excited
to see that happen.
RYAN GREGG: Oh, nice.
It started rolling
out a couple days
before the big
announcement today.
And like, how quickly people
have picked it up, and started
using it, and writing
blog posts about it
before we could even
comment on the product,
it's been really neat to see
these very creative solutions
coming out.
STEREN GIANNINI: Actually,
speaking of creative solutions,
one of our alpha tester was it
running "Doom," the video game,
on Cloud Run.
So of course because
it's request based,
it was sending one
image at a time,
but the FPS was
quite good actually.
And so that means literally,
you can run anything,
including as soft of a
binary of a video game
in a serverless way.
RYAN GREGG: It was
really cool too
because with concurrency, there
were a whole bunch of people
hitting the same instance
at the same time,
so it's like 80 people playing
the game simultaneously.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And it
just scales right up for it.
RYAN GREGG: And it just
scales right up, yeah.
STEREN GIANNINI: So
to be clear, Cloud Run
is not a replacement
for Google Stadia,
and this is not a use
case for Cloud Run.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: No
video games on Cloud Run.
RYAN GREGG: That's right, yeah.
STEREN GIANNINI: It's not
a video game platform.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It can handle
anything, but probably not
raw motion.
STEREN GIANNINI: I think
this was more an experiment
than anything else.
RYAN GREGG: You're not
going to get the 4K, 60
frames per second experience.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Just a
proof of concept, yeah.
RYAN GREGG: That's right.
STEREN GIANNINI:
Yeah, yeah, it really
shows you can run any
stateless workload
on the serverless environment
and paying for what you use.
GABRIELA FERRARA:
Well, with that,
I want to thank you for
being here talking to us.
Is there anything else
that you want to talk about
that we didn't cover?
STEREN GIANNINI:
No, give it a try.
RYAN GREGG: Yeah,
I think just we
can't wait to have your
listeners try it out and send
us feedback.
STEREN GIANNINI: You
know, in a few click,
you deploy a demo container.
In a few more lines of code,
you deploy your own container.
Give it a try, really.
GABRIELA FERRARA: I will.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Awesome.
Thanks so much for joining us.
GABRIELA FERRARA: Thank you.
RYAN GREGG: Thank you.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Very,
very cool interview.
It was a lot of fun.
You know, Gabi and I were
really excited to hear more
about Cloud Run, like you
said, being announced at Next.
Amongst all the
other announcements,
I think this one
was kind of special.
And a lot of people are
really looking forward
to being able to
play around with it
and understand more
about what that looks
like in the spectrum of all the
different serverless offerings.
MICHELLE CASBON: So Mark,
if I wanted to get started,
how would I go about
playing with it?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That
sounds almost like a question
of the week, perhaps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
OK, well, let's
answer it as though it
were some kind of
question of the week.
You know, obviously,
it is come out now.
It is in beta.
So anyone can actually just go
to console.cloud.google.com,
and just kind of using
your normal GCP account,
go ahead and start
playing around with it.
But you might want a little
bit more support in doing that,
so there are actually
some tutorials
that are right into
the documentation.
If you go to documentation
at the Cloud Run page
and click on Quickstarts, you
can see a couple of guides
there.
But you can also go to the
Codelab site which has a few
actual guided kind of
step-by-step tutorials--
very similar--
that let you kind of walk
through those things.
I hear that Coursera
and Qwiklabs
will start to work on
more content there,
so I'm sure there'll be
more resources out there.
But the reality is that
you just need a container,
and you're pretty much good to
go using the serverless part.
So anyone who is
kind of, like, even
with a bare-bones
Dockerfile, you
can kind of get
an application up
and running in Cloud Run
within a couple of minutes.
So they showed it all on stage.
And it was very cool to
see how quick and easy
it was to spin up.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Yeah, that's right.
So those codelabs--
that's something
that our team works on.
We actually author those.
It's some Googlers.
The Cloud Run one was written
by Alexis Moussine-Pouchkine.
He's one of our colleagues.
It's a great one.
And he was working all the
way up until the last minute
to make sure that everyone has
access to it, so check it out.
I hear it's a great experience.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So with all of that
being said, and I
know everyone is still
kind of recovering
from Next because it
was an exhausting week.
MICHELLE CASBON: It
was a very long week.
It was action packed.
There were just so
many announcements.
And I think Mark and I
both over the weekend
just sort of turtled up and--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Very little
got done, except for, like,
mental recuperation.
[MONK DRONING]
MICHELLE CASBON: Yes,
mental recuperation.
That's a great word for it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: A fancy word
for doing nothing and just
trying to stay alive.
MICHELLE CASBON: So
where do we go from here?
What are we doing this week?
Where will we all be?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
right now of course,
we're recording
this podcast [CHIME]
as a lot of our colleagues
are out traveling.
So Gabi is over at PyTexas.
You know, Jon and Mark are
actually over at the East Coast
Gaming Conference, right?
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
they'll be out there.
You, and I, and
probably everyone else,
will actually be going
to Google I/O. That's
coming up in a couple of weeks.
MICHELLE CASBON: That's right.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
And then you're
going to somewhere very
fancy in May, right?
MICHELLE CASBON: Yes, I'll
be at KubeCon Barcelona
with a few of the
other Kubeflow folks.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
That sounds exciting.
MICHELLE CASBON: It is.
I'm just planning my travel now.
I'm a little bit behind because
of all of the Next work.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
With all of that,
I'm going to take some time off,
maybe lie low for a little bit,
and then obviously get
back up for I/O coming up.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Yeah, so if you're
in the Bay Area the
first week of May
or the second week of
May, I believe, join us
for Google I/O. Mark
and I will both be
there, along with a number
of our other colleagues.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It'll be
hopefully, a little less
than Next-- a little
less extra than Next was.
MICHELLE CASBON: I think so.
We're not primarily responsible
for this conference, which
helps, but I will be
at the Codelabs booth.
So if you want to do more of
those hands-on walkthroughs,
you could do the Cloud
Run walkthroughs.
There's a whole host of
brand new codelabs for you
to try out at Google I/O.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh, and I
forgot to totally mention that,
like, all the Google Cloud
Next stuff is also on YouTube.
So like, if you
couldn't make it out
there, be sure to go to YouTube
and check out the videos there
in case you want a recap on
a couple of cool sessions.
And then I'm sure
that after I/O, we'll
probably have some content
going up there as well.
MICHELLE CASBON: You'll see
Mark Mirchandani's face on a lot
of those videos-- he was
involved in quite a bit
of video production--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I'm so tired.
MICHELLE CASBON: --and a
few of our other colleagues.
And you'll see any
of the sessions
that you didn't get
to see in person.
You can find most of
those recordings up there.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Very cool.
All right, well,
we'll let everyone go.
Thanks, everyone, for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
MICHELLE CASBON: Thanks.
See ya.
[MUSIC PLAYING]